الولايات المتحده جاهده للاحتفاظ بتفوقها
الجوي على مستوى العالم بعد التقدم الكبير
الذي ظهر خلال السنوات الاخيره في القدرات
الصينيه وكذلك على الجانب الاخر ظهور
تكتلات دوليه لتطوير مقاتلات من الجيل
السادس
الخطط الامريكيه لتطوير اسلحه فرض صوتيه
لقواتها الجويه شهدت مؤخرا انتكاسه هذه
الانتكاسه جاءت بعد قرار الغاء برنامج مع
شركه لوكيد مارتن في هذا الاطار نتيجه فشل
التجارب الاخيره على صاروخ جو ارض فرد
صوتيه للحديث عن الخطط الامريكيه لتطوير
القوات الجويه وايضا مستقبل برامج الاسلحه
فرط الصوتيه في الولايات المتحده ينضم
الينا من واشنطن رئيس تحرير مجله القوات
الجويه السيده
اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتانيا بدايه اين
موقع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في مجال
الاسلحه فرطا الصوتيه امام روسيا والصين
خلال هذه الفتره
اعتقد انه من المهم ان ندرك ان الولايات
المتحده قد احرزت الكثير من التقدم مبكرا
في الماضي في مجال الاسلحه فرط الصوتيه
لكنها لم ترى مزايا هذا التقدم بعد ذلك
وخلال سنوات الثلاثين الماضيه ولا سيما
خلال فتره زمنيه التي اعقبت احداث الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر بدات كل من الصين وروسيا في
تطوير اسلحه بعيده المدى واسعه الى اكتساب
مزايا تفاضليه وقد نجح البلدان في تحقيق
الكثير من التقدم في هذا المجال وبوسعي ان
اقول ان البلدين متقدمان على الولايات
المتحده فيما يخص التكنولوجيا فرط الصوتيه
وهو امر يدفع باتجاه تغيير بعض الابعاد
الاستراتيجيه لكنني اعتقد ان الاسلحه فرط
الصوتيه هي اكثر اهميه بالنسبه للصين مما
عليه بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
فيما يتعلق بمقاتله جيت وانت الصينيه بكين
اعلنت بانه هذه المقاتله تمتلك القدرات
الشبحيه على الجانب الاخر فيما يتعلق
بالولايات المتحده هل هذا يعني ان
المقاتلات الامريكيه فقدت احتكارها لمثل
هذه التكنولوجيا ومنعكاسه على القوات
الجويه الامريكيه كذلك
اعتقد ان ما يميز طائره الشبح هي قدرتها
على القيام بعمليات المراقبه على مستويات
المنخفضه ومعرفه تهديدات القادمه وهي امور
قد لا تتاح لاجهزه الرادار والواضح ان
الصين ادركت قيمه تكنولوجيا الطائرات
الشبح التي طورتها الولايات المتحده وساعت
الحصول على هذه التكنولوجيا لتعزيز
قدراتها العسكريه بها مكتفيه بذلك اثر
روسيا بهذا الشان واعتقد ان الصين احرز
التقدما اكبر مما حققته روسيا في هذا
المجال وربما سوف يزيل هذا التقدم الصيني
بعد عناصر الاحتكار الذي تتميز به الطائره
الشبح الامريكيه دون ان يعني ذلك حرمان
الولايات المتحده من جميع المزايا التي
وفرتها لها الطائره الشبح الامريكيه
الطائره الشبح تجعل مهمه تحديد الاهداف
القادمه اكثر صعوبه وتعقيدا وتقلل فتره
الانذار المبكره
لا اعتقد ان امتلاك الصين خاصيه الشبح لن
يغير الامر كثيرا بالنسبه لامريكا لانه في
نهايه المطاف عندما تتم اضافه قدرات جديده
لتحديث الدفاع الجوي فهذا يقلل من تهديد
طائرات الشبح وبالتالي فهي لن تؤثر على
دوله تمتلك نظام دفاع جوي متكامل
فيما يتعلق بمقاتلات الجيل السادس هناك
الكثير من المشاريع سواء في اوروبا وحتى
في الصين او حتى في اسيا في هذه المرحله
لكن فيما يتعلق بالمشروع الامريكي لتطوير
مقاتله من الجيل السادس كيف تقيم البرنامج
الامريكي في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لطائرات الجيل السادس يستطيع
الانسان القول ان قاذفه بي 21 التي دخلت
الخدمه في شهر ديسمبر الماضي كانت اضافه
كبيره اما فيما يخص طائرات الجيل السادس
فهذا باعتقاد موضوع قابل للنقاش لان الامر
يتعلق بما توفره الطائره الشبح من قدرات
يضاف اليها عناصر الحرب الالكترونيه
ولغايه المتمثله في قدرته على التخفي عن
اجهزه الرادار مع الاستعانه بالوسائل
التكنولوجيه للتصدي للتهديدات القادمه اما
بالنسبه للاسلحه من الجيل السادس فهي
تتميز بقدراتها التدميريه والقاذفه بواحد
وعشرين تتميز بوسائل التحكم التي تتمتع
بها الطائرات المقاتله فضلا عن قدراتها
الجويه الخاصه والمعززه بقدرته على
استخدام الطائرات المسيره التي تحلق الى
جانب الطائرات المقاتله وهو امر يضيف
المزيد من التعقيدات التي تواجهها نظام
الدفاع الجوي التي التي تتصدى لهذه
الطائرات
مصر دبيس على ذكر الطائرات المسيره هناك
اهتمام دولي كبير الان بمجال الطائرات
المسيره لكن هل تعتقد بان الطائرات
المسيره التي تعمل بتقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي هل تؤثر على الطائرات التقليديه
في يوم من الايام وكذلك على مهنه التيار
ايضا بشكل عام
بالتاكيد ما سيكون واضحا للعيان هو ان اي
قائد لطائره من الجيل السادس او الخامس
مثل طائره اف 35 ستكون لديه قدره تحكم ليس
في الطائره المقاتله فحسب بل وفي الطائره
المسيره التي تحلق الى جوار طائرته ايضا
بشكل تعاوني ويشمل ذلك مشاركه الطائرات
المسيره في الحرب الالكترونيه كما يمكن
تزويدها باسلحه اضافيه ناهيك عن قدراتها
الهجوميه المستقله التي قد تتمتع بها مثل
الصواريخ جوجه وفي هذه الحاله يصبح الطيار
قادرا على تحكم في جميع هذه الوسائل
واتخاذ القرار بسرعه اكبر